[Música]
preparador que son de los seres humanos
podemos modificar genéticamente nuestros
alimentos para producirlos en el
desierto o incluso construir tecnologías
para cultivarlos en la antártida pero un
tercio de todos los alimentos que
producimos los desperdiciamos cada año
1300 millones de toneladas terminan en
la basura cada año mientras que 800
millones de personas todavía hoy padecen
desnutrición extrema podemos desalinizar
agua de mar o incluso capturarla del
aire condensando la humedad pero aún así
800 mil niños al año mueren por no
disponer de agua segura
podemos clonar una oveja o generar vida
en una probeta pero condenamos a la
extinción a 200 especies cada día somos
capaces de desarrollar pistas de esquí
artificiales en un medio del desierto
pero destruimos el equilibrio climático
y ambiental global sabemos cuantificar y
asignarle precio a todo pero ya no
reconocemos el valor de nada
somos paradójico so quizás se trata de
otra cosa
no será tal vez que nuestra razón
instrumental en la que tenemos la
capacidad de desarrollar técnicamente y
transformar la realidad no supo dialogar
con la razón práctica esa es la que se
construyó en nuestros mundos simbólicos
y también donde se piensa el deber ser
del hombre en el mundo no será en suma
que hemos equivocado muy fuertemente
nuestro camino cuando la ciencia nos
dice y la realidad lo corrobora que
solamente nos quedan diez años para
evitar una crisis climática sin
precedentes y una crisis existencial de
igual dimensiones no podemos seguir
hablando con eufemismos hay que decirlo
con claridad no no somos para lógicos
somos aunque nos cueste aunque nos duela
o aunque lo neguemos antiéticos como
sociedad global a la luz de la crisis
planetaria que hemos desatado sólo
podemos reconocer que nuestro
comportamiento ha ido a contramano de
cualquier noción de valor y de justicia
si seguimos pensando que es un problema
técnico solo reforzaremos los errores
del pasado el problema no es técnico el
problema es filosófico y es conceptual
nuestro vertiginoso desarrollo
tecnológico y nuestra capacidad para
transformar el entorno no han sido
regidos por principios éticos pero en
lugar de reconocerlo preferimos generar
falsas dicotomías
como que el cuidado del entorno debe
subsumirse a la razón imperante del
mundo que nos dice por ejemplo que
debemos avanzar sobre nuestros bosques
nativos para producir más alimentos o
divisas para sostener el crecimiento
económico o esa otra lógica según la
cual seguimos necesitando construir
objetos innecesarios y contaminantes
sólo para mantener en funcionamiento la
insaciable maquinaria del consumo pero
no hay más tiempo para estas
equivocaciones y tampoco hay otro cambio
otra posibilidad mejor dicho que la del
cambio radical básicamente porque
nuestros errores conceptuales no pueden
ir más allá de los límites físicos que
nos impone la naturaleza
o encontramos la forma de desarrollarnos
en ese punto de conjunción entre la
razón instrumental y la razón práctica
donde impera la ética o aceptamos la
posibilidad de que el experimento humano
haya fracasado
podemos hacerlo pero una de las
actitudes más importantes que deberemos
tener será la de abandonar la soberbia
humana que nos ha hecho creer que somos
todo poderosos y capaces de encontrar
soluciones a cuanto desafíos hemos
creado que vale la aclaración los
desafíos que hemos creado en nosotros
mismos y solo nosotros mismos en su
lugar deberemos volver la mirada hacia
el único organismo que ha sabido
conciliar ese desarrollo instrumental
con ese desarrollo ético a través de la
diversificación de la vida y de la
riqueza constantemente para aprender
humildemente de él
y cuál es ese organismo
la naturaleza así de simple así de
grande y así de revolucionario pero como
puede ser que hayamos equivocado tanto
el camino es porque en algún momento de
nuestras construcciones simbólicas
envalentonados en el positivismo
cientificista y el desarrollo
tecnológico y también muy narcotizados
por el éxtasis del consumo hemos optado
por romper la unidad primigenia que nos
unía a la naturaleza realizamos un corte
terminante entre el pensamiento mágico y
el pensamiento lógico y rompimos para
siempre la unidad del cosmos nos es
íntimos de la naturaleza y al hacerlo
decidimos reducir la cosa u objeto a
disposición de nuestros afanes y
caprichos pero olvidamos en el proceso
que al cosificar a la naturaleza nos
estábamos cosificando a nosotros mismos
porque nos guste o no nosotros
somos naturaleza la verdadera y más
grande grieta que hemos creado
es la que separa al hombre y la
naturaleza
volvamos a reconocer la naturaleza
volvamos a integrarnos a ella volvamos a
aprender lo que nunca debimos
desaprender volvamos a escuchar lo que
nunca debimos es oír hagámoslo podemos
hacerlo hay algunas cuestiones básicas
de cómo funciona la naturaleza
en algunos principios rectores que
podemos emular y cuáles son esos
principios o lógicas que utilizan la
naturaleza primero utilizarlo localmente
disponible a excepción de la energía del
sol que nos viene todos los días y a
todos por igual la naturaleza no
necesita de importar ningún tipo de
recurso extra para su funcionamiento
siempre utiliza lo que tiene a
disposición en su ámbito local
no genera residuos recicla todo por el
contrario nosotros y de manera inaudita
hemos utilizado nuestra increíble
capacidad creativa para dar lugar al más
absurdo de los conceptos el de basura
concepto este que la naturaleza nunca
concibió y que nunca tuvo cabida en ella
en la naturaleza nada se desecha todo su
producto de un proceso un ser vivo
termina siendo un insumo para enriquecer
a otro proceso o ser vivo generando
siempre muchísimo más valor y
enriqueciendo la cadena de vida propia
de la naturaleza
todo está conectado simbióticamente no
conoce procesos lineales
por el contrario nosotros nuestro
pensamiento lineal y mecánico en la
naturaleza la interconexión de lo
existente se fortalece constantemente y
esa característica la hace resiliente y
también la hace inabarcable al
conocimiento humano premia la
cooperación y se opone a la
monopolización muchísimo más allá de la
competencia como factor imperante lo que
verdaderamente prevalece en la
naturaleza es la interconexión y la
articulación constante entre los
diferentes reinos y organismos y eso es
lo que posibilita el funcionamiento de
los ecosistemas sin la cooperación no
funcionarían los ecosistemas
promueve la diversidad nunca excluye ni
discrimina sino que crece y se fortalece
en la diversidad
pero lo más revelador de todo sobre
cuando luego de entender estos
principios de la naturaleza que son tan
distintos a los principios con los que
funcionan las sociedades humanas nos
detenemos a meditar en el indicador que
resulta de ellos y que es el indicador
de éxito que utiliza la naturaleza para
medir su desarrollo y que estoy
convencido es el mismo que deberíamos
utilizar nosotros porque al hacerlo
terminaríamos de comprender por qué
podemos aseverar que la naturaleza
deberá funcionar de un modo ético
conciliando la razón instrumental con la
práctica y porque en su lugar nosotros
únicos seres racionales en el concierto
de vida que es el planeta tierra hemos
actuado contramano de la ética natural
y cuál es entonces el indicador de éxito
que utiliza la naturaleza
ni más ni menos que la vida misma
a lo largo de 3700 millones de años
desde los primeros organismos
unicelulares que aparecieron en la
tierra en la actualidad la naturaleza ha
sabido diversificar la vida hoy en día
tenemos conocidas más de 10 millones de
especies mientras que se estima que el
número real es muchísimo mayor
es asombroso
pero en los tiempos de la estadística y
las mediciones del imperio de la big
data y la cuantificación de todo hemos
cerrado en la definición más básica la
elección de nuestros indicadores nos
equivocamos en la elección de nuestros
indicadores el pp y el crecimiento
poblacional el aumento del consumo y la
expectativa de vida todos los
indicadores que 1950 esta parte han
validado un modelo que a pesar de sus
éxitos relativos que fueron muchísimos
error en sus fundamentos éticos si
midiéramos nuestro desarrollo con el
indicador que utiliza la naturaleza
comprenderíamos la magnitud real de
nuestro fracaso de 1800 esta parte el
crecimiento de las poblaciones humanas y
de su pp y per cápita ha sido
directamente proporcional a la extinción
de especies de animales vegetales e
insectos esta es la verdadera magnitud
de nuestro fracaso nuestro paradigma
rado nos está llevando a la sexta
extinción masiva que ha conocido nuestro
planeta
más de un millón de especies en riesgo
de desaparecer
y con ellas extinguiremos su belleza por
supuesto
pero también sus servicios ecosistémicos
y lo único que haremos será incrementar
el tiempo de aniquilación de nuestra
propia especie una vez más el
pensamiento lineal de nuestras
sociedades nos impide ver la
interrelación sistémica de lo existente
pero insisto
podemos corregir este derrotero y hay
infinidad de ejemplos y proyectos
concretos que demuestran que es posible
hacerlo aunque hoy no les voy a
compartir ninguno
porque el error más grande sería pensar
que la réplica de ejemplos exitosos
puede corregir nuestras equivocaciones y
no lo hará porque el cambio que se
requiere es muchísimo más profundo el
cambio que se requiere es conceptual es
filosófico y es radical porque exige
poner en jaque a gran parte de nuestras
cosmovisiones de nuestras construcciones
simbólicas y culturales y también
redefinir desde sus bases
gran parte de nuestra escala de valores
piensan que es exagerado
estoy dispuesto a cambiar mi parecer
completamente pero antes solo que lo
hagamos un ejercicio le pido a todos
aquellos que sean capaces de reconocer
todas las marcas que aparecen en esta
imagen que levanten sus manos
muchas gracias puede bajarlas ahora una
vez más
le pido a todos aquellos que sean
capaces de reconocer las especies de
árboles a la que corresponden estas
hojas que por favor levanten sus manos
como puede ser que seamos tan capaces de
reconocer determinadas construcciones
simbólicas del ser humano y que es un
lugar seamos tan incapaces de reconocer
de reconocer elementos esenciales que
hacen el sostenimiento de la vida sobre
la tierra
no habrá revolución tecnológica ni
alerta científica ni catástrofe
climática ni riesgo inminente de
extinción que nos despierte de nuestro
letargo ni que corrija el destino
planetario si no trabajamos primeramente
sobre nuestros fundamentos éticos y
conceptuales
re definamos nuestros valores
re definamos el concepto de éxito
redefinamos muy profundamente nuestra
relación con la naturaleza
y luego sí sumémosle a esto toda nuestra
increíble creatividad y capacidad
científico tecnológica
hagámoslo y demostraremos que finalmente
el experimento humano era valió la pena
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]